I think I just like figured something
out why this sucks
yeah was really sucks this sucks more
than anything that has ever sucks before
the disappointments room was directed by
DJ Caruso who also made disturbia and
stars Kate Beckinsale and it's about a
family that moves into an old house and
in the Attic of this old house they find
a room and this room holds a very
frightening past and one kate beckinsale
stumbles into this room some shit starts
happening in their house and in her mind
and to be honest I really don't actually
know what's happening the best way for
me to describe this movie is to say that
my favorite part of the entire
experience was that I got to see it
alone there was no one in the theatre
just me so you know that was kind of
cool besides that was pretty much a
living hell the disappointments room is
a movie that was made by relativity
studios this studio has since gone
bankrupt and a ton of films are now up
in the air this film was on the shelf
for a long time a few years and I think
a lot of the people involved with it
we're probably thinking oh god they're
releasing it great I'm sitting here
right now struggling to locate anything
positive to say about this movie and
it's really hard Kate Beckinsale is an
attractive woman and the director of
photography clearly has a professional
career lighting films this one is really
bad people I struggle to comprehend how
it was made and I'm not exaggerating I
went to this movie and I was actually
kind of excited I like Kate Beckinsale I
like horror films quite a bit and I like
scary creepy old houses and so this
movie had those things going for it and
I do like Disturbia that's why I had the
blu-ray so I was like okay DJ Caruso
this could be good it's written by wet
worth Miller who's an actor really well
known for Prison Break he also wrote the
movie Stoker some of the worst films
I've seen so far this year movies like
Norma the north or sell these films at
least have a beginning and a middle and
an end and it feels like you're watching
a movie I knew how long this movie was
going into it according to IMDB it's
about 92 minutes I looked at my watch at
one point and was shocked to discover
there was like five more minutes in the
film and it didn't even feel like it was
over in fact it felt like nothing had
happened because nothing happens
this entire film makes no fucking sense
the husband character in this film I
found insufferably annoying at one point
someone asks him what he does for a
living and he says that he plays xbox
and takes naps while he watches his wife
work what a stand-up guy Kate Beckinsale
plays an architect in this film and I
guess that's the way of explaining why
they're in this really shitty old house
that no one would ever want to live in
because she's an architect and I guess
she's going to fix it up and the film's
way of showing her being an architect
and it's kind of like she just stands
over blueprints and goes like no we're
not architects stuff right just to that
measure that and I'm an architect it's
one of those movie jobs you know where
it doesn't fit the character it doesn't
feel real it doesn't feel like it's
natural or authentic at all but the
writers needed that to be in the script
so that they could get the characters to
do the things they want them to do in
the movie and it's just it's atrocious
this entire film honestly feels like an
amateur movie and I know it's not
because it's directed by DJ Caruso it's
written by Wentworth Miller these are
not amateur talents what happened I told
you I'm big on structure this movie
doesn't have it it's a long series of
horror movie cliches that are
unforgivably unscary
if I was tired I could have fallen
asleep during this movie and slept like
a baby nothing frightening happens it's
it's actually unbelievable this movie
got made in his release in theaters
it's not scary there are no characters
in this movie there's a very poor
attempts to weave a tragic backstory
into these characters lives that has
nothing to do with the horrific elements
of the film which spoiler warning you
don't have to see this movie just don't
see it
keep your money you deserve your money
if you have money you
you keep it you put in your wallet and
you don't give it to this film so I'm
going to spoil some shit because it has
to happen it has to I I'm sorry kate
beckinsale basically realizes that she's
living in a house that has a
disappointments room up in the attic a
room where the former tenants many years
ago put their deformed child because
they were disappointed in this child
because she wasn't perfect this is
apparently a real thing in history
because parents were barbaric or
something I I don't know none of this is
harnessed into anything that is actually
frightening in this movie the horrific
elements of this film the film's title
the disappointments room the entire
thing surrounding all the marketing of
this movie this this room that we're
supposed to be so scared of it's barely
in the movie the movie is about like the
tragedy of their past and it doesn't at
all fit into what's actually happening
with this room and she's investigating
and starts believing in ghosts then she
gets visions somebody hangs himself in
their yard there's a worker who comes to
help them with things in the house who
constantly hits on Kate Beckinsale that
goes nowhere she gets visions of killing
her child and things that just don't
make sense there's this really awkward
dinner scene or she yells at everybody
ah the husband's entire arc is basically
him just going well what's that over
there is that a cat come come come here
come here son come here come here come
here son come here there's a point in
this movie where they do the horror
movie exposition scene you guys know
what I'm talking about every single one
of these movies has it where the
character visits an expert of some kind
in the field of the paranormal who
explains to our protagonist what's
happening at that point in the movie I
checked out I was like okay they've
given up entirely but I still of course
paid attention and I got to say really
honestly nothing in this film makes
sense there's ghosts in the house she's
had a bad past with trauma and the
husband is upset and maybe she might
commit suicide and then nothing there's
nothing there's no character arc there's
no character depth of any kind the
characters in the film end in the exact
same place they were in the beginning
they go nowhere the only thing that
changes is our knowledge of things that
have happened to these characters in the
past the characters themselves go
through no evolution of any
kind so the characters are boring the
performances are mediocre at best the
quality of the direction in this movie
is basically reduced to the art of
framing something that's happening in
front of you and making sure that
everything is in the frame and okay
action cut there we guy let's let's move
on to the next shot what are we going to
do for this shot angle the camera over
there and make sure that you get Kate
Beckinsale's face in frame okay where's
where's the hookers for later I really
don't feel like going on anymore this is
one of the worst movies of the year
easily it's one of the worst horror
films I've ever seen and I've seen a lot
the disappointments room of course gets
an F yeah I don't see it it's really
really not worth your time I mean it is
it's not at all like sometimes when I
see a movie I think I wasn't that great
it's not worth your time guys don't
waste your time don't waste your time
with this movie don't guys thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes don't see this film
[Music]